so our first topic for today is
anime dads The Good the Bad the Ugly
okay let me talk about the bad okay
[__] Goku all right can we talk about
how [__] of a dad Goku is did he like
raise his child at all I don't think you
could say this about most animators at
least Goku was there most of my dad's
just don't exist you know okay let's
Okay because there's so many bad anime
dads let's talk about the goat anime
dads first who are the like greatest
anime dads of all time the greatest
anime dads like I'm trying to think of
anime dad's icon
I'm trying to think who raised their
child oh oh okay okay it's a niche one
but uh did you ever watch sweetness and
lightning yes that's a golden anime dad
I did not watch it oh [__] you've just
opened up an entire do you remember that
one yeah yeah I remember that you've
just opened up an entire [__] door
for me now like [__] every everyone
with a cute little daughter like spy
spikes family yep I
it's funny that they're like a fake
family and then they're more wholesome
than most like real anime they're all
put together than most people yeah right
the thing I find most unbelievable about
spy family is that he hasn't hit it yet
that's just like that's true that makes
no sense it's not part of the mission
corner
I just want to spin off or it's just
like he gets a new Mission it's just
like breed
make more children it's like oh [__] I
need more children and make it more
convincing don't adopt it looks I have a
pregnant wife it looks more realistic oh
honey I'm gonna get you pregnant it's
for the mission dude sweetness and
lining I remember the pot that I [__]
I mean well not the part just like the
the thing that I absolutely loved about
that show have you watched sweetness
okay so it came out a few years ago
obviously because I watched it
um but uh it's basically
but uh it's basically uh it's it's a
slice of life right basically yeah it's
a sex life show um essentially where uh
yeah there's a there's really cute like
I think she's like all the best dads are
in Slice of Life yeah to be honest it's
like this five five or six year old
daughter the mum is dead I mean it's
like it's literally it's not a spoiler
it's literally the first scene the mom
is dead Okay um and it's basically a dad
trying to come to terms with uh raising
their only daughter but the daughter is
like really I guess like even though
she's super super young she's like I
think she's like four or five years old
or something right
um she like you know and obviously they
go through the hardships of like you
know being a single parent and stuff
like that and being a single dad but the
daughter is so [__] supportive and
wholesome to the dad that every dude who
watched that show was just like I want a
daughter like you you are like The
Golden Child of children that I want to
have and it's it's just so [__] good
you just you've just reminded me of
something yeah the uh I think I think
the manga or show that started this
entire like wholesome dad daughter
relationship Trend I'm talking about
good Dads What About usagi Drop oh
I never watched Crusaders I mean it's
good
look good is uh good is a subjective too
uh he's a great dad at the beginning
super degenerate dad near the end okay
so I'm gonna spoil usagi drop it's
[__] I'm never gonna watch it it's
years old if you haven't watched usagi
drop I doubt you would have watched it
yeah uh I doubt this is going to change
anything now but uh okay so I could drop
the anime [__] great yeah you see
this wholesome father-daughter
relationship where I can't remember the
exact concept of it but I believe the
daughter is like
um he adopts this daughter
uh and it's the anime is this
exploration of you know him learning how
to be a dad and kind of like fathering
this adoptive daughter and uh learning
feelings and stuff and then it goes on
learning feelings learning some
wholesome feelings really nice I'm not
gonna watch it yeah and then uh people
went on to read the Manga which was you
know it was very very wholesome until
like kind of kind of like the ending uh
because uh obviously because the manga
is way more longer running than the
anime went uh the daughter grows up
and uh
she uh discovers that uh she has
developed feelings
for her adopted father yeah I can't we
get anything that's normal basically
basically the Creator I think read
oriimo and went yeah
they just become [__] weird because
the thing is this was a really like
unironically like a wholesome innocent
show it was a really good show
wholesome and innocent about this
father-daughter relationship I think the
ending comes and you're like no please
don't you have to question the state of
the author yeah you'd be like what's
happening in your head what was going on
with this this felt like the right
storyline you know what like something
like this I could accept if it was like
a hentai or something yeah you know I
can accept that I've seen worse things
in hentai but don't give me like every
every other [__] other stepmother is
like [__] their childhood is
different all right
you wouldn't get it but like don't give
me like 10 volumes of some of the most
cute yeah
family coming of age story and then just
turn around and be like what if I what
if we just like made it official yeah
but in a completely different relation
relationship yeah and everyone was like
because I remember reading the manga as
well because I I I watched the anime
first and I was like this is great but I
heard there was a continuation yeah and
so I was like all right sick I bought
all the volumes reading it I'm like okay
this is great super cute and then it
literally happens in like the last maybe
four or five chapters okay and I'm just
like
yeah is this like a spin on fire red
like what happened because because the
worst part is right because at first
it's just like the daughter like
realizing her feelings and you're like
please don't please don't let this be
like the ark and the Direction the Story
is going uh I I think the the moment
where I kind of like just threw the
manga on the floor was just when okay
the daughter is [__] young she don't
know what the [__] she's doing yeah but
then like the father accepts it as well
I'm like no no you're meant to be the
mature one here the one time you had to
be an adult you were just like nah so
it's secretly a big debate for grooming
yeah yeah
you're getting love it's just a one big
group it's one big grooming mom yeah
unfortunately yeah so we've decided to
do a you know uh telling of the priest
story uh from the side of the priest
where he could come you know yeah it's
just like what okay
um a good dad is Aaron Jaeger's dad a
good dad
do you believe that there are some kids
that are just doomed from the beginning
but it doesn't matter how good the dad
could be where the child is just a spawn
of Satan yeah do you believe that that
exists yeah yeah I say so would you say
irony falls into that most likely I'd
say this is a complicated
we can make this entire podcast of was
Aaron Yeager right
discuss just have the fortnite meme it's
fortnite okay was never wrong people who
haven't watched it yeah yeah another
another character then I'll pitch to you
is Kirito's dad a good dad
Kirito's dad even though he wasn't there
but is he a good dad for raising Kirito
oh like how like how so he turned out as
Kirito is that like did he do the job
are you talking about Kirito's dad or
Kirito as a dad Kirito's Dad wait oh
yeah Kirito was a dad too yeah Dad who
adopted with uh uh yui with uh [__]
Arsenal right I blocked that from my
videos
because that's the moment where so I
went to [__] very early on very early on
yeah Kirito has a dad did you know that
did you know that does he actually make
an appearance yeah really is he good
um wait when huh when in alicization Oh
okay that's why
because spoiler I've actually been
watching someone that's online
I've actually because I actually had
this realization the other day that um
I've watched every piece of like Sword
Art Online media that has been released
in anime
um
yeah it was weird because at the end of
alicization there's a moment where
Kirito has a scene with his mother and
father to be like I think I know what to
own what I want to be and what I want to
pursue growing up and I'm like [__] me
it took 70 like 100 [__] episodes to
get to this point what the [__] we're
actually doing this now what are these
problems
what kind of parents are there they're
normal parents of course they are
actually they were just like can you
please decide what the [__] you want to
do with your life piss your life away
with video games I know you're like an
epic gamer but please choose a career
path but I'm like you know what I can I
I can actually kind of respect that
someone had to say it someone had to be
like you to uh being a beta is not a
viable career option I'm sorry it's not
a thing yeah actually there's one scene
at the end of alicization where his
mom's just like next time you go into a
[__] game that could like kill you
can you like tell us first like this is
the third time this has happened are you
please just [__] tell us what do you
doing just find a better way to end it
like okay do you know how he had to
explain to the doctors when we had to
carry you into the hospital with a
[__] gaming headset on yeah you can't
like you get to you get addicted to VR
chat once okay I can understand the
third [__] time happened you almost
died from this and you don't tell us
this [__] please tell us oh my God
actually actually like becomes a VR chat
mute yeah yeah and like when he's 40.
yeah on the topic of like usagi dropping
like degenerate dads and stuff like that
there's that I remember like recently
there was an anime that was just the
opposite of that I think okay
um I think the anime was called like
Higa Hiro and I really oh yeah I really
really hope that the manga hasn't gone
some Saucy Roots right well I mean it's
originally a light novel so it's
probably going down gonna go down the
Saucy road because the the thing that I
liked about that was it's a show where a
guy basically picks up this runaway like
middle school high school girl and
literally the start to every hand yeah
yeah and you'll and you watch the first
episode and you're like this is uh this
is this is very very sus yeah this is I
I I've seen enough hentai snow where
this is going
um and then it turns out every time like
the girl tries to be even remotely
sexual he's just like get away from your
child I do not I am not interested in
children and I'm just like man is this
the standard we have in an anime where
someone's saying commendable yeah yes
someone's saying no child get away from
me I do not find you interesting uh
that's that's like commendable now again
no I was just like damn this is a really
this is a really original route that
this uh this anime has gone down to be
fair it kind of is like and that's kind
of the sad thing right it's like if you
see an otaku like resist that oh it's
just like oh wow all right he gets
[__] oh all right he's different you
mean he's picking up this uh he's he's
picking up his Runway high school girl
just to help her yeah just just just to
be lucky that doesn't just to be a Good
Samaritan yeah and then the girl was
like why are you gay I don't think
that's a good dad is Subaru's dad from
good dad I think he's pretty good right
he's not in the show yeah he has a
motivational moment with him he's like
come on kid don't suck I was like
yeah it's like your mind though wasn't
it yeah maybe it wasn't his mind but is
that does that count as a dad if it's a
dad it's like an imaginary attack what
if the imaginary dad has more impact on
your life than the real dad